Computing on the cloud essentially means that your data is on
someone else's computer.
And with the global average cost of a data breach
being 4.45 million dollars,
or a violation of the EU's General Data Protection
Regulation (GDPR) being a hefty fine,
it's easy to admit that remaining security compliant
with your data is extremely important.
That's where Data Security Posture Management (DSPM) comes into play.
DSPM solutions puts you at the helm of your cloud
data inventory, interactions and access,
then gives you a platform to help
mitigate risks, find and remediate vulnerabilities, and ensure
a compliant security posture.
It does this with three things in mind: visibility,
movement and protection.
And to explain these things,
I'll use this example topology diagram.
First problem, where is our data stored?
It's not just in the databases.
Sensitive information
gets passed to all components of your topology.
What if sensitive information is in an instant message
or Excel spreadsheet or PDF document?
What if someone creates their own version of the database
for development purposes?
Then most likely this database is not going to have
the same controls as the original.
For that, you need visibility. And DSPM solutions
help to identify all locations where data resides,
even shadow data
that's not specifically identified in your official inventory.
Next problem, where does the data go?
Well, to know where the data goes,
you need to know its access points.
Sure, we have these connections in our topology diagram,
but what about all of its users?
Who has access to what?
What kind of third parties do you interact with
and what access do they have?
For that,
you need to know the movement. And DSPM solutions help
to analyze both potential and actual flows of data.
Last problem, what kind of risk do we face by having this data
and all of these different components?
Well, all systems have vulnerabilities.
So which components are the most vulnerable?
Are the third parties you interact with responsible
enough for the data they have access to?
If a data leak did happen, do you have the safeguards in place
to mitigate the total effect?
For that, you need data protection.
And DSPM solutions help to uncover these vulnerabilities
in your data, interactions and access and compliance controls,
and then gives you a risk based prioritization
of these vulnerabilities and remediation recommendations.
Okay, so once we have these three things in place,
then we can start getting some payoffs.
First, reducing exposed data.
For this,
you can make sure that your data is securely shared with only
its intended recipients
and inaccessible to unauthorized parties.
Then you can remove any sensitive information from your cloud
operations or various SaaS applications.
Next up, you can prevent data leakage.
And you do this by safeguarding the data
and making sure it doesn't go into the wrong hands.
You can monitor your flows and transactions between different
cloud environments and your various SaaS applications.
Along with the previous two benefits,
you can better mitigate third party exposure
by analyzing all of your third party vendors
and what kind of data they have access to.
Then determining whether or not they have
the necessary certifications to handle such information.
And once you have that information,
you can decide whether or not you're going to maintain
or exclude their access to that data and streamline
this risk assessment of your third party vendors.
Last but certainly not least,
you can monitor data transactions.
And this allows you to oversee data transactions
between different countries and regions
that may have those data retention regulations in place.
This way allows you to remain security compliant.
So, if you're going to take away anything from this video,
know that data security is very important.
And if it's not obvious by now,
there's a lot of issues that go along with it.
So to help you out,
check out Data Security Posture Management solutions.
Thanks for watching.
Before you leave, please remember to hit like and subscribe.